[Music]
[Applause]
kevin durant is under contract staying
with the nets but the key word that
stood out with the press release
was partnership
brian windhorst espn senior nba writer
kind enough to join us here
am i making more out of one word here
brian than i should it said the
partnership with the two will move
forward
well with this nets team i'm not sure
you know i think they're probably right
now going about week to week um but
i think i think making any predictions
or assumptions about this nest team is
going to be risky business um
but they came through the storm here
uh at the start of this off season
sean marks it was one of the more
aggressive press conferences i can
remember in recent years you know he
basically came out and
and you know without calling out players
names basically said we can't go forward
like this with this team we got to reset
this the way our team operates
and i was like good luck to you because
you know from the day that uh kd and
kyrie irving walked in you basically you
know gave them the the the keys to the
franchise and sort of let them have
control i don't know how you're getting
it back
and the way that they have gotten
through it dan is leverage you know that
when
when when those guys came there they
didn't have much leverage the nets were
you know a borderline playoff team with
no superstar players and they were like
whatever it takes you want to you want
us to sign deandre jordan for 40 million
okay you want to potentially have a say
in the coach okay um and that you know
giving them that kind of rope it didn't
work
and so the team was like we can't go
forward with this so
how do you get you know now they've got
the leverage so number one they knew
that there wasn't a huge market for
kyrie irving not that other teams didn't
want him
it's just that nobody had money this
summer it wasn't a summer where there
was a lot of cap space and so
they had to you know kyrie at one point
said hey listen i might opt out uh i
might go to the lakers and take a 30
million dollar pay cut it seemed crazy
but you know they had to they had to go
to bed at night thinking about that um
they had kyrie saying hey i want to work
out a sign in trade give me permission
to go talk to other teams they go okay
go do that they knew that the leverage
was in their favor there and they won
that one and then when durant said i i
wanna be traded you know they knew that
they had a four-year contract in their
favor and they had to probably swallow
some pepto um more sleepless nights
but when they talked with other teams
dan and those teams made offers they
were like no we're treating you a
superstar player on a four-year contract
we're not backing down and so
even when two weeks ago
durant asked for remarks and steve ashby
fired
obviously on its face that was extremely
disconcerting
but if you could peel back the initial
shock layer there was durant saying
underneath there there's a path to me
coming back
and rescinding this it was a pretty
extreme path
and they kept their nerve because they
had the leverage
and ultimately the leverage paid off
will it continue to pay off for the next
nine months i guess we'll wait and see
okay but i can't imagine that first
meeting between kyrie kd and steve nash
i mean is steve nash safe
okay so i do think it was a remarkable
step that steve nash and i mean this is
a
i know steve a little bit this is a
proud man
um
this is a a relentless competitor we all
saw him in his career i mean this is a
guy who
you know through the back part a couple
years of his career couldn't play
without laying down on the court
to deal with his back injuries and he
just played through it i mean this is
not a guy who gets pushed around
but he flew to la this week or whatever
it was i guess uh you know two days ago
and he sat in the room with kd and i'll
say to you i'll say this dan i've
covered the nba for 20 years you've seen
more nba seasons than i have i have seen
situations where a coach
gets threatened by a star player
gets the backing of management and
becomes emboldened
or they're like okay
now i now you know that you can't get to
me and it actually works i'll give you
an example right off the bat lebron
james first year in miami
they start nine and eight
he
uh you know they could debate how much
he he and the rest of those guys wanted
eric smalls to step aside and pat ryan
to come in riley put him right back in
their place back spoelstra and i
remember being there
the day after it you know the stories
came out that lebron wanted spoelstra
fired
i thought we might see like a tentative
eric spoelstra
he was absolutely as strong he's ever
been
obviously there's been times where the
star doesn't like the coach and it
doesn't work but i actually think they
may have given
the franchise reset a chance to work
here
because they use their leverage against
these two guys
and whatever was said in that room
between durant and nash
in theory carries over the starter
training camp i i can't believe i'm
saying these words
and i'm certainly not running down to
place a bet on the nets championship
i'm
cautiously optimistic about the nets now
because i like their roster
and i think this might have cleared out
some scar tissue
and i think they got a chance now
what's this mean for kyrie
in brooklyn
he has an incredible incentive to have
a low stress
great season
he has seen that his windows to leave
brooklyn are not that open now there's a
lot more cap space next summer than
there is this summer he'll have more
options um
uh but uh he has never been sort of
under this kind of scrutiny before he's
got one year on his contract
and he needs to prove that it's gonna
work and so
i don't know if kyrie
has it in him to be consistently focused
on basketball and to deliver the way the
nets came to do he may not have it he he
may be at a point where
he you know you know we obviously know
that on individual nights he can be
spectacular but if it's ever going to
happen it's going to happen in this
situation i think
that nessa put themselves in the best
chance to succeed with this kyrie
that they could and it doesn't mean that
it will
but
i think there's a level of buy-in now
buying in the summer and buying in
january two different things but i i do
think there's a level of buy-in and the
one thing i also will say
throughout this entire process
we've never seen any indications
of durant and kyrie
splintering in fact if anything i think
durant has been too loyal to kyrie so
ultimately whatever steve nash is doing
takes back seat to the way those two
operate together and i will say
that ben simmons is one of the great
mysteries in the entire nba
you can tell me that ben simmons is
going to give them nothing this year and
i would say that's possible you could
also tell me that they're going to
deploy a lineup with ben simmons playing
center
joe harris and seth curry playing
shooting positions with with uh with
kyrie and durant and you could see an
incredibly
talk you know you talk about the death
lineup that the warriors used to run
that's the death lineup on steroids
that i would be incredible i'm not
saying they're going to play at 30
minutes a game that would be incredible
i don't know whether ben simmons can
manage it but you know there's all of a
sudden a whole bunch of different things
this team can do that has me thinking
about them in basketball terms instead
of what's gonna happen with their star
players talking to brian windhorst espn
senior nba writer if i said ben simmons
will be an all-star over the next four
years or be out of basketball
after four years
what would you bet on
i'd bet on him being an all-star
because i think
there is a path for him to be successful
in the nba
and
uh he doesn't have to be a superstar on
this team
he doesn't have to make shots seriously
dan he could go through the entire
season and not shoot a ball outside the
paint and it would be okay
if he defends which is what the nets
need if he's able to be a a significant
defender and like if they build i mean
i am not an xml strategist but i can
tell you that if you build an offense
where you would have a six foot ten ben
simmons operating the offense out of the
post
with those four type of playmakers
i can see it working i can see there
being a role here where he can be a star
in that role
again i'm not wagering on him making the
all-star team this year but i can see it
and also
i was saying this for the last couple of
months and it felt weird when i said it
but i'll say it again
the nets kind of had a good off season
they they they traded for royce o'neill
who's exactly the type of player that
they need
and they got him in my mind for cheap
they got him for a protected future
first round pick
they signed tj warren who hasn't played
in two years but it's a very low risk
high reward type signing they re-signed
patty mills and joe harris and seth
curry both had offices and surgeries and
again in theory you know you you get
some guys coming off surgery here but in
theory all those guys will be healthier
there's a lot there
that i'm
think could be fertile for ben simmons
to work with
yeah maybe ben can be
a draymond green type of point forward
for this team although draymond can
still you know occasionally knock down a
three-pointer uh the the lakers
off-season
lebron signs the extension
looks like they're not getting kyrie
are they ready to go into battle with
this roster that they have right now
they shouldn't be um
you know i would i would guess that at
some point they're going to make a
significant trade
it may not be before the start of the
season it may be later on and it's
probably going to involve westbrook the
real question is
what
what is the demeanor of russ gonna be
because
the ex interview that he gave at the end
of last season was
extremely troubling it made me wonder
how they ever thought it would work
unless he completely
did an about face in what he said it
sounded to me like he was never invested
in this success
and so darvin ham heard that exit
interview before he took the job and
almost
almost his first order of business when
he got the job after signing his
contract was publicly laying out exactly
what he needed russell westbrook to do
now i have seen things happen in the nba
i am not going to sit here and tell you
that what he wants russell westbrook to
do which is to
be a defensive role player and to be a
screen setter and stand in the corner
and wait for the ball to come to him and
make a shot uh you know one out of every
seven possessions
i'm not going to sit here and say that
it is zero chance of that because i've
seen stuff in the nba
but
the
the tenor of the way russ was talking
throughout last season
what i know about him as a person as a
player
i find it very doubtful he is he is
going to actually be able to follow
through with that so the question is
how long are they going to experiment
with that dan are they going to
experiment with that
the first 10 days of training camp are
they going to do it in their you know
four or five preseason games are they
going to spend october in november
experimenting with that and if it
doesn't work how much damage is there
because when you look at the western
conference let's just be reasonable the
lakers finished 11th last year i know
they had injuries but teams have
injuries you know you're going to assume
that a 37 or 38 year old player is going
to miss games in lebron and you're going
to assume anthony davis going to miss
games if you don't assume that you
haven't watched his career so they
finished 11th last year
which teams are they passing
that finished ahead of them okay utah is
coming backwards i'll give them that
san antonio who finished one spot ahead
of him in tenth is coming backwards okay
i'll give them that they can pass those
two teams by the way portland's standing
right next to them
they're getting damon lillard back
they've upgraded their team sacramento
kings i can't believe i'm talking about
this but they've got a shot to make the
play-in tournament okay they've improved
their roster
who are the lakers passing
with this current team
they're not passing very many teams and
that's why
when you look at their roster and you
say they're playing team at best you
know that that offends some lakers fans
but that's just a fair way to look at it
i think from the trade standpoint which
is everybody wants to know what trade
are they going to make
i think based on me talking to some
teams out there
i think they are going to be willing to
trade those two first-round picks
but they're not going to be willing to
trade those two first-round picks just
to get off of russell westbrook or to
potentially improve themselves from
projected ninth to projected seventh
they're gonna use that to try to leap up
which is why they were instantaneously
interested in kyrie irving and whether
or not a trade like that presents itself
is gonna depend on whether how far
they're gonna be willing to go into
those assets i'll leave you with this
donovan mitchell uh you know
obviously it's not a secret but it's
been quiet
uh it feels like
uh
cleveland's may be involved in this or
another team's involved in this i don't
know if that's meant as you know
kind of getting the knicks to step back
up here with danny ainge but
is donovan mitchell on another roster
opening night
i i would be very surprised if he is uh
with the jazz after the trade deadline
uh opening night we'll see um there's a
when you talk to executives in the
league including some teams that have
talked to the jazz
they will say
nobody can
probably beat what the knicks can offer
and that this entire thing is a dance
to get the knicks
to a price that the jazz want
um
the knicks i think are in a position
where they know that and they're not
going to try to bid against themselves
and the x factor that we don't
understand here by the way like i do
think there's other teams who have made
offers and i do think that there are
other offers that the jazz would
consider but i don't think there's a
better offer out there
that they're going to take in lieu of
what they can get from the knicks and
they're certainly not gonna do that
six months before the trade deadline
that just doesn't that's that's bad
business but one thing we don't know
the jazz are going to tank this year it
seems like that's what they want to do
if they start the season with donovan
mitchell mike conley bogdan bogdanovich
pat beverly on the roster i mean that's
not a playoff team
but they are not going to go 2 and 15.
they are going to win some games and i
don't expect donovan mitchell to play 15
minutes and take eight shots i expect
him to go
for the scoring title why wouldn't he
you know why wouldn't he see what
russell westbrook did when he won mvp
after durant left and go i'm i'm going
for it so the question is
how worried are the jazz about
maybe
a missed opportunity by not going into
full tank leaning into a full tank
situation and would that
cause any sense of urgency for them to
want to do that before the start of
opening day
the knicks seem the way their hand the
knicks are handling this
they're not going to come in and just
blow everybody away with offers they
seem like they want a hard line so i
guess we'll see
there is definitely a game being played
out there
with information right now and i i kind
of see i don't have all the information
but i kind of see
where things are being dropped and
leaked and saying you know boy we really
love this other offer we really love it
um so it's it's you know since i have no
skin in the game it's easy for me to
smile as i watch it but it's going to be
a massive transaction
whether the knicks do the deal or not it
potentially could define their next
couple seasons
always great to talk to you brian thanks
for joining us thanks for having me dan
have a good day that's brian windhorst
espn senior nba writer